how does Ant-Man become Ant-Man Ant-Man
was Eggman because of research that I
didn't on the quantum realm he also
stole your suit but he's not the real
Ant-Man no you're the animal I am and
the Ant-Man he is a fraud how do Ant-Man
Powers work check out the original I
think it's available on DVD how small
does Ant-Man get well pretty small very
small
how big can Ant-Man get that he's right
that makes that fairy boat look like a
toy boat in your bathtub how does
Ant-Man communicate with ants I really
think most of the answers are going to
be found in the original film ant talk
guys they have a group WhatsApp they
have a group they have a group one they
all go hey ants what sand that's it
what's that